Blade Runner 2049 shows us an exhausted
world a world that is kept alive only by
artifice by technology the earth is dead
fertility is impossible and there's
universal alienation images showing a
disjunction between heaven and earth
thought and body meaning and fact will
repeat themselves over and over and it
is the search and the miraculous
possibility of a new world rising out of
death a search for the possibility of
true life something real as this joining
of heaven and earth of masculine and
feminine towards a child which is the
driving force of the movie
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world there are
many possible images of the end of a
world and the movie strings several of
them together everything happens in
California which is the western tip of
Western civilization the place where the
Sun sets where the day ends we see this
giant wall which artificially holds out
the ocean holding off the flood but the
strongest image is one of saturation
when something is full when something is
saturated it means it has exhausted its
possibility and in this case like an old
woman having reached menopause the world
of Blade Runner is no longer fertile the
opening scene shows us this saturated
world too many buildings too many
structures too many people the main
character is dozing off in his flying
car the first image of Ches general
numbness
he's a fabricated slave a useful body he
sees himself as a creature without a
soul as he tells us later he in fact
does not have a name kay is only a
serial number
replicants are artificial people like
Pinocchio they are wooden puppets
without strings like the Golem of Prague
their superior strength is generated by
man to serve man but is always in danger
of turning against those they are made
to serve this is of course an image of
the body itself with all its own
volition zall that its own desires which
don't always align with our will but
it's also the most intimate
understanding of Technology as an
augmentation of the body Plato describes
the body as the chariot of the soul
which brings us along to our goals but
can turn against he who
the rains so all the images of
technology causing demise the nuclear
bombs which render parts of the world
uninhabitable
the overwhelming advertisement are all
there to excite the passions the the
farming of food is done in a toxic
climate all of these images culminate in
this technology of the human which is so
close so intimate so melded to man
himself that it is both the ultimate
tool and the ultimate danger all at once
and the blade runner's slice between the
two sides as the movie begins cake comes
to a site where stands a dead tree the
last residue of a fruitful connection
between heaven and earth masculine and
feminine and there as an image of the
dead earth he discovers the dead mother
beneath the tree the finding of the dead
mother is provoked by a hint of the
possibility of life a flower on the
toxic earth s'okay has killed the giant
who guarded this mystery and now the
mother presents herself as a riddle k
must answer a search for meaning which
also becomes a search for identity you
could say that the movie is yearning for
an alignment of extremes a place where
all the disjointed dualisms can align to
create something real a miracle a child
in this sterile world it is a search for
three things the three terms a search
for the father a search for the feminine
the wife but mostly the mother and it is
a search for how they come together in
the miracle of a child
in this search for alignment disjunction
is emphasized over and over K knows his
memories don't fit with his actual past
his artificial girlfriend joy appears as
an ideal loving partner embodying the
masculine fantasy of a wife serving him
dinner
she's the encouraging partner and the
seductive lover all at once yet she's
only a ghost a bodyless fantasy she
cannot be the mother and were reminded
of that when shown images of the
advertisements which feature her out
there in the city the unresolved wallet
e of meaning and fact spirit and body
appears strongest in food and insects
when k eats his dinner a hologram of a
tasty meal is projected over this bland
synthetic gelatin and also enjoys
searches for intimate contact with K she
must find a body and her relation with K
is then portrayed as a hybrid a duality
of soul and body which does not fully
align for seeing through this extreme
imagery we should recognize that this
disjunction between thought and action
ideal and embodiment even the
disjunction between our image of
ourselves and our actual place in the
world are something we live with every
day and so more disjunctions come we
encounter several images of the feminine
the lieutenant who is the guard of the
city like Athena the virgin goddess like
the Holy Virgin herself who was the
guardian of Constantinople the feminine
in its role of virgin is the keeper of
purity the wall between the inside and
the outside and of all people the
lieutenant sees the danger of the
situation that humanity has created a
wall
separating that which is augmented and
artificial which that which is human and
natural but as the world exhausts itself
she knows and sees with the the mystery
of this new mother that the wall might
come down and flood her world and she's
right so she wants to destroy the child
the possibility of bridging the two
sides for this would be the end of
humanity as she knows it but she's also
blind to the sterility of the situation
how all is exhausted and that this
miracle child is also an image of the
future the revolutionaries are presented
to us toward the end of the movie led by
a woman as well they embody the fears of
the police lieutenant and want to free
the replicants not only free them but
replace humanity they also want the
child and they believe this child will
lead their revolution against humanity
of course their plans do not align for
the child when we meet her it's fragile
creative and sensitive and is not in any
way a revolutionary in fact she works as
a supplier for Neander Wallis in order
to create a better life for replicants
the Andrew Wallace is the tyrannical
father a blind technocrat who appears as
a Nimrod figure often shown on a strange
Island seeing the world only through
technology his language and action
places him as the paroxysm of hubris
speaking as if he is a God creating
angels searching for the one thing he
cannot replicate through his technical
means fertility life the mother as a
natural potential for the future Wallace
has to manufacture the future through
extreme means through synthetic foods
and synthetic replicants he wants the
child so that he can control the
so that by having fertile replicants he
can solve the problems of this world
which is empty of possibility by sending
out more colonies to more new places
because he overestimates his capacity to
control he does not seem to see the
danger of the revolutionaries and how
self-replicating replicants would turn
on their makers as they did in the past
and so you have four factions who are
searching for this place where heaven
and earth met or masculine and feminine
produced a miraculous child these four
factions together explore the
relationship between identity order and
chaos the shape of the future and how
all of these align kay is searching for
the father and the child as a solution
to his identity the possibility of
crossing over and like Pinocchio
becoming a real boy
the lieutenant wants to preserve the
limits and the borders of the world
prevent the replicants from crossing
over and in that way prevent the flood
of chaos and confusion Wallace wants
control to master the father in order
that he relinquished the child so that
Wallace can also master the feminine and
continue to saturate the universe with
his vision the revolutionary replicants
want to be free they wish to kill the
father so that the feminine child can
lead their revolution against Wallace a
nice correlated pattern a contrapuntal
theme cells within cells interlinked and
the spinning blood black emptiness of
Ches Numb existence k goes to find his
father
twice once he goes out into the fiery
desert of post-nuclear
las vegas and here we see Deckard hiding
in the strange vestige of what Vegas
represents lug
an artifice gambling as the edge of
reason and order and we also find the
past fragmentary incoherent memories of
a distraction culture the broken-down
residues of the feminine has desire
inducing fantasies and of course Deckard
amidst this forgetting himself and his
alienation from all that he loved by
alcohol the second time Kay goes to get
Deckard it's not in the fire but in
water well we'll get to that a bit later
the child the question of the child is a
vital importance at the beginning before
the clues come together there's another
place where things are not aligned the
gender of the child masculine or
feminine and we need to back up and look
at this from a perspective of the whole
movie we want to understand the symbolic
structure maybe understand the politics
as well there are two presentations one
masculine with K and the other feminine
dr. anise telling K is a hunter and
executioner like Deckard a replicant who
kills replicants and that way he is all
that is severe and oppressive a tool of
the system if we think of the child as
the future we have to wonder what would
be that future dr. Anna on the other
hand is presented as not only the
daughter but the mother her name honest
Ellen seems to be a play on maristela a
title of the Virgin Mary referring to
her as the star of the sea Anna itself
means grace or favor her mother Rachel
like the Rachel of the Bible had been
barren and childless
and through prayer had received grace
and her room was open and God
remember Rachel heated her and opened
her womb Anna is also shown in stark
contrast to the rest of the movie as
soon as we see her you know Anna
luscious green forest creating and
molding an insect
unlike the masculine father God Wallace
who creates and destroys with cold
calculation and control on a lovingly
fashions memories to make the lives of
replicants as rich as possible so we're
presented with two opposing views of
creation the cruel control of the blind
masculine and the loving tenderness of
the feminine Mother Earth figure when K
is finally faced with things lining up
this happened with the shattering of his
fantasy world his fantasy girlfriend is
destroyed he descends only into the body
he is saved by the body part of his
intimate encounter the prostitute and
then down down into the flooded basement
where he is told it was his imagination
wishful thinking he is not the child the
future is female and he leaves
disillusioned told he should kill the
father to protect the child this
understanding of his disjunction is then
brutally repeated as he meets one last
time the holographic projection of joy
once before and insisting that he is a
real boy joy had wanted to give him a
name Jo a name to fit a true identity
but now he discovers that Jo Chow is
just a generic name used by the joy
program to entice desire he sees the
flashing sign everything you want to
hear everything you want to see it had
all been an illusion and then all
becomes aligned
no more confusion the general
representation of the masculine and
feminine does not bode well for the
politics of this movie it's all the
usual and exhausted wailing at the
patriarchy all of its there but it seems
like the actions of K at this point save
the movie from just being propaganda K
had been an executioner and once again
the revolutionaries want him to play
that role but instead he decides to go
out past the wall out into the chaos and
saves the father from sinking into the
deep and having found something real
having found something undeniably real
as a revolutionary woman tells him that
dying for the right cause is the most
human thing we can do and he has found
the right cause he has found something
real not technological monsters created
by Wallace not the revolutionary
delusions of a replicant army but the
relationship between dexhart and Anna
the possibility of a father and a
daughter being reunited the possibility
of life on a human scale as the true
future the embodiment of that coal
related pattered in the game a system of
cells interlinked themselves into land
within cells interlinked within one stem
within one stem and against the dark at
all white fountain played
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved
I'd love to read your insights and
questions in the comments section you
can also share this video on social
media to your friends and as you can
please consider supporting us
financially through patreon or PayPal
you'll find those links in the
description below